welcome back to new rock stars when
ultron infinity tried to eat galaxies or
when the celestials are about to pop
planets like pimples where is the tva
they possess for all time always the
ability to stop little ass guardians
from playing with toys but they turn a
blind eye to multiverse wide destruction
did the watcher arishim the judge and
kang have some kind of oath to stay off
each other's lawns what is this a
florida suburb oh that's right florida
references are back because papavos is
back in town
and this is rogue theory the show where
we pitch the wildest theories for the
nerdy titles that we love i'm eric boss
going rogue with me today is eternal
friend of the show it's jessica
clemens
[Laughter]
for podcast listeners it was all four of
us at the same time trying to sync up
that brown note
also with us today is uh from his very
own branch timeline tommy bechtold
[Music]
oh no
no this is we were unsubscribing
[Applause]
things have devolved so fast
theory what a mess uh and finally feel
free not to uh complete this rule of
three's turkey kang of the big hang gang
i can't say right empty
um eric i
don't understand your
accent
yes
you also need to introduce mt as the
watcher himself because he's exactly
like the watcher
i got the
it's making them uncomfortable well
speaking of the watcher with ultron
infinity blazing a war path through the
multiverse and the celestial's now about
to eradicate earth with this emergence
the tva appear nowhere in sight
suggesting that either all of this
destruction is unfolding according to
the sacred timeline or that he remains
death could have left the sacred
timeline undefended and allowed all this
chaos i want us to talk about the
relationship between kang and the
celestials and the watcher do like
celestial supersede timelines as we know
them did uwatu have some kind of secret
deal with kang i just want to know why
didn't the tva ever stop any of the
madness that happened and what if what
do you guys think i don't think this is
true at all what i'm about to say but i
always had like a dream that the tvas in
their own pocket universe where we can't
see it and so that's why they're off the
radar of a wu-2 kind of and also now
that the tva is ran by a different
variant of kang i feel like that tva
doesn't really want to do anything that
involves what the watcher is really
doing i think it's more involved of like
destroying just becoming the next war i
don't think it has anything to really do
with those two but i do want to believe
that the tva doesn't is in a different
universe of its own which i know is like
hard to try to make in the mcu
especially with the watcher being able
to see everything but i just want him to
miss that one little bit of world and
it's the tva because they're so sneaky
yeah that's what i want that's what i
want from the tva's pov yeah i i
visualize the tva kind of similar to
what jessica says like if i can use this
as an example the turtles in finding
nemo the the sea turtles that go into
that stream they live outside of that
stream and then they only enter the
sacred timeline when they go into that
that that uh that stream of water that
current of water now i i think kind of
this basically this piggybacking on what
jessica said but like
i think what happened is you know this
is kind of a fulfillment of the prophecy
of what uh he who remains uh the one who
remains kang that got killed set which
was like if you kill me
the other people who are going to come
into the other kangs that are going to
come into power are going to be way way
worse and way way less protective of the
timeline and of the events of what's
going on you know they're gonna there'll
be much more chaos and war and carnage
so all of these things that are
happening are kind of just a payoff of
that line in my opinion yeah i i think
now what we're trying to conceive is
this thing called pocket dimensions or
pocket realities right so uh at the end
of what if we had this big mirror
dimension sphere that encased doctor
strange supreme and then within that he
had a little russian nesting doll of his
own one with uh killmonger and zola
tugawarian over the infinity stones
i think you might be honest something
jessica that the tva could be contained
in another kind of pocket dimension that
is kind of like unwarpable through
external means of like historical
ruptures uh to any other timelines but
that's what made it so terrifying at the
end of loki to see some kind of change
happen from within meaning that the
person who did it must be someone who
has the the keys to the kingdom but mt
you and i have kind of talked about this
idea that maybe uh
watching the watcher and kang the
conqueror could could be old friends or
old rivals do you think they're more
likely to be friendly or like kind of
from lost the jacob and the man in black
i kind of could see both means in case
man i it's it's really tough to know
whether or not uatu and you know he who
remains or king would like each other
because he remains literally interfering
with everything uh he's like which is
very much against what uatu is all about
um but i think that they could have a
relationship and it would be very weird
if they didn't have a relationship
considering that they are both watchers
they both monitor the timeline um but i
think the reason why the tv didn't show
up in um in what if is because at the
end of loki we do have you know this
whole chaotic thing kick off what i
think is going to happen is that the tva
is going to stop being
like that police force and more of like
an army i think that we're going to have
multiple tvas headed by multiple kangs
fighting each other and so while they're
doing that then we have all this what if
stuff because like they're just doing
their own thing trying to like you know
figure out who's gonna take charge of
everything but then like we have ultron
and uh zola and killmonger doing their
own thing and because the multiverse is
in chaos um so but i don't know but with
the whole uatu and kang thing
it's it's hard to say if i mean i think
that they definitely do know of each
other and they probably have 100 have
had a conversation but i don't know if
they would ever work together i don't
yeah and it's tough to say i have a
question no i have a question for you mt
is there any world where because and
maybe not but is there a world where
kane could or uatu could be a version of
kang um only because you just mentioned
how they both are
watchers and overseers of the universe
how they're now like in different
timelines doing bigger parts of each
other is there a world in which that
could because this uh came from a planet
that made him kind of different
slightly different than the other
watchers obviously he left and then was
just helping the fantastic four in the
comics so what if this is there a world
in which that could be possible that is
that's my question yeah 100 i think that
you know with kang's like well
i think that it's it's very unlikely
considering that the watchers are their
own race of people their own race of
aliens and likes and i think that marvel
is trying to keep that separate from the
whole kang thing just to keep just to
make people less confused but i think
that there is a possibility because kang
you know works with time he could
potentially go to the beginnings of the
watcher civilization and be like i'm
daddy watcher now i was the one who did
it um it was my seed uh so i think it's
possible i don't know uh
don't know where the big head is
see
well the watchers are using the watchers
i'm sorry i'm this is how i think i
always like do some weird like i thought
you would just become no i love it why
jessica
wow
love thinking
put my jessica in the mario movie right
now do it
please put me as wario i'd be so good
i'd be so good um
but
oh now you got me forgetting where i was
no sorry sorry but it sounds like what
we're kind of agreeing upon is this idea
that even though the tva they aren't
really bound by the order the causality
of time like they can fix problems that
are going to happen in the future
really it's only now that in our other
kind of dimension of time that things
kind of broke at the end of loki that
enabled the fogged glass to be more
transparent in what if so that dr
strange supreme and that ultron infinity
can kind of look over their shoulders
and see through it and then it kind of
makes the borders a bit thinner makes
the glass easier to break through but uh
i wanted to ask like about the
celestials right so like it seems like
the celestials might have some kind of
brewing rivalry between themselves and
the watchers but like are the celestials
bound by the tva
like is there timelines with celestials
in them or the celestials just above
different timelines i think
your second part and what we're seeing i
think they're above it would be the same
ones above all right and they just don't
really interfere with stuff that are so
minor because they don't care about such
minor things like the tva which is the
tva is minor to them um compared to
other things that are happening like
what what we're seeing in eternals
that's such a big deal that it's like uh
the world disappeared everyone
disappeared that's enough to cause such
a huge ripple for them to notice but
something as small as the tva probably
isn't that big of a deal so i think it's
all of them overseeing the entire
the entirety of everything right you
know there's there's kind of checks and
balances on all these different cosmic
forces and that the tva really because
it's like kang's little phony
bureaucracy that it created it's kind of
like the backdoor um
cia you know or nsa that just kind of
spies on everything and keeps everything
and just aligns everything to the way
they're working whereas the the
celestials are kind of the figurehead
leaders of the of the multiverse of the
universe uh where they can kind of
create galaxies they can create the the
structural order of everything and
decide when it gets destroyed so i guess
you could argue they could probably also
destroy the pocket dimension that the
tva is contained in but it's just kang
so damn slippery yeah yeah i think so i
agree with that completely i agree with
that completely i think they could tear
everything up if they wanted to i think
that well in terms of celestials and
universes i think that
the watcher
may be above the celestials in terms of
like um observing because i feel like
every universe has their own
like bunch of celestials like they'll
they have their own gamut on the
gatherers zirin all all the boys and um
and but they
are the custodians of the universe in
their own way like i like to view the uh
the celestials as custodians they're
like all right we're just maintaining
life
and so
um but and so i think that that was
pretty mean
is your custodian singing his stupid
song
as he murders a million people
i just
but no because of this i think that the
celestials and the watchers sort of just
leave each other alone because the watch
is just like all right these guys they
sort of
they're they're interfering with people
and i don't like it but like
they do have a cosmic purpose and like
they they're they're you know they're
multiversal constances so i'm just going
to let them do their thing though i
don't really like it or are we just
saying that like none of these
these like neither celestials nor
watchers are like apex
predators in a reef like they're all
just kind of like have their own jobs
some are
charged with keeping the bottom of the
ocean floor and the coral free of like
bacteria while the others are charged
with like you know
making sure the water is filtered with
not enough there's enough plankton
around to keep everything alive and fed
and none of them are great white sharks
that are just killing machines that
don't care yeah and kill them
i think that's it that's why i was
saying like checks and bounces on each
other that they all kind of need each
other
uh to maintain the balance but like i
what i want to see is like some big
boardroom meeting where like a seat at
the table is kang a seat at the table is
the watcher or some other watcher seat
of the table is one of the celestials
and then every other kind of cosmic
being is there and they all kind of say
like all right here is our oath
i will not interfere but i will be
watching everyone but i want to know
here okay here's my oath i will clear
planets that get too powerful and start
to become like us okay cosmic accord and
then and then kang's like i'll keep an
oh
i think these variants of kang's are too
wide oh yeah
wait pulls his own pants down
he's coming like whoa whoa whoa okay
after they all leave here comes the
custodian
well they really made a mess of this
board room there's cliff bars everywhere
i love this i love the idea of this i
think kang is just so goofy that i feel
like owatu and um or just the watchers
in general and the celestials make more
sense working together and recognizing
that they need each other and then
there's the kang variants that are just
honestly here to cause more destruction
than helping the than anything now that
like the original kang is gone where i i
liked his chaotic energy of like i'm
doing this for good we're doing this to
protect them from myself um now that we
released all the other ones i'm like uh
now you're just here to damage the
entire world you're making it worse uh
so i i it's like those two need each
other this kang yeah get him out of here
get him out of here we don't need him
he's off he's pulling down his pants
showing his wedding ring
but no to the um to the point of the
whole huge boardroom of like these
cosmic entities i really loved how in
the comics when they did do that when
like you had your your bit like your
your master orders and your lord chaoses
and your uh
one above all just like convening with
everybody just being like listen shit's
going down thanos is being a bad bad boy
what are we going to do
like basically stuff like that so i i
really hope we see that in the mcu very
soon well uh for that round uh jessica
you're gonna get the point for this
suggestion of a tba in a pocket reality
or pocket dimension i i think that's the
i've heard now at least until the next
mcu thing changes everything that's what
i'm going to be clinging to for the next
uh what three weeks until eternals hey
why are we all gonna go see that for my
birthday
yeah tommy
yay
[Music]
everybody's in this four-hour movie
foreign on my actual birthday clifford
the big red dog
oh my and some could say that's the
story that's your origin story the big
red dog that's right
or as i like to call it pacific rim 3.
[Laughter]
there's a dog jumping off the buildings
oh why are you rooting at me
clifford doesn't talk
all right well we got more of that we
gotta talk about this big casting news
from guardians of the galaxy volume
three but first you gotta grab yourself
some cool limited edition shirts
inspired by venom let there be carnage
that's from our merch partners at epic
hero shop they also have great shirts
and other merch inspired by shanghi
suicide squad and other properties that
we've been loving the last few months
find those shirts and all the great
merch options at newrockstarsmerge.com
but guys there is nothing sexier than
confidence and bluetooth can help give
you the confidence where it counts
bluechu is a unique online service that
delivers the same active ingredients as
viagra and cialis button chewable
tablets and at a fraction of the cost
you can take them any time day or night
so you can plan ahead or be ready
whenever an opportunity arises the
process is simple sign up at
bluetooth.com consult with one of their
licensed medical providers and once
you're approved you'll receive a
prescription within days the best part
it's all done online so no visits to the
doctor's office no awkward conversations
and no waiting in line at the pharmacy
bluetooth tablets are made in the usa
and prepared and shipped direct to your
door in a discreet package so if you
could benefit from some extra confidence
when it's time to perform visit
bluechew.com bluechu can help you and
we've got a special deal for our
audience try bluetooth free when you use
our promo code rogue at checkout just
pay the five dollars in shipping that's
bluechu.com promo code rogue to receive
your first month free visit
bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information and we
thank bluetooth for sponsoring the show
also if you dread looking at your credit
card statements you are not alone the
weight of debt can be crippling but
upstart can help you on your path to
financial freedom upstart is a fast and
easy way to pay off your credit card
debt with a personal loan all online
whether it's paying off credit cards
consolidating high interest debt or
funding personal expenses over a million
people have used upstart to get one
fixed monthly payment with a clear
payoff date rather than looking at your
credit score alone upstart considers
other factors like your income your
current employment credit history
defined you a smarter rate for your loan
and you can check out your rate without
impacting your credit score in minutes
for loans between one thousand to fifty
thousand dollars you can even receive
funds as fast as one business day after
accepting your loan find out how upstart
can lower your monthly payments today
when you go to upstart.com
rogue that's upstart.com
r-o-g-u-e
don't forget to use our url to let them
know that we sent you load amounts we
determined based on your credit income
certain other information provided in
your loan application upstart.com rogue
all right guys big news this week actor
will poulter was cast as adam warlock
for guardians of the galaxy vol 3. james
gunn confirmed it the actor from maze
runner
from black mirror midsomar and dopesick
is going to be playing adam warlock of
course the genetically perfect being
from the early fantastic four comics who
later was pivotal in the infinity
gauntlet storyline in the comics where
he wielded the gauntlet played a major
role in uh resolving that crisis and in
the mcu we uh met him really in the
guardians of the galaxy volume 2
post-credits scene with the defeated
aisha on the sovereign plotting her
revenge against the guardians with adam
gestating in a golden cocoon so what
will be adam and aisha's plan against
the guardians in volume three and could
adam appear actually earlier like in
thor 11 thunder next year or in the
guardian's holiday special next december
what do you guys think i really want to
see
um
adam warlock
turn on aisha i want him to come out of
that cocoon and then immediately be like
you created me for destruction and i
don't want this and then kill all of the
sovereign i think that would be great
and then
eventually i want what i really want is
him to somehow work
like the story ah this is okay this is a
stretch i want the storyline to be
eventually them trying to turn they meet
him and they're like
oh buddy we were trying to outrun the
same person what a great idea and he's
like just destroying people in his way
he's just like i don't know who you are
we're gonna destroy you but they're like
wait you can work with us i don't know
why maybe it's because i like adam
warlock his story he has so much that i
don't want it only to be used in
guardian three i want to see him later
in other franchises so i want him
i want him to stay in the movie working
alongside the guardians this is rogue
theory so i'm just going rogue i know it
seems like it might be impossible but i
want them to the movie to be them trying
to get him to be on their side and
trying to teach him because he's brand
new he's learning he's just going to
destroy anything in his path so i want
them to be like this isn't right you're
not supposed to destroy things and
they're just going to try to get him on
their side so i hope that's what happens
i hope he turns on aisha he just turns
on everybody but they bring him back and
he starts fighting with the guardians
okay okay i definitely think the
guardian's team up is a very likely one
considering that we do know that you
know this might be our last time with
this iteration of the of the guardians
and we could see the guardians look
differently and because adam warlock was
originally part of the guardian's lineup
um at least at one point anyway um we
could definitely see adam warlock play a
bigger role and like maybe we'll have a
more beefed up like cosmic guardians
team like we've seen recently in in
comics with you know like ghost rider
and all them it was a huge stacked
uh he guards the galaxy team but i think
with guardians of galaxy vol 3 i think
that
the high evolutionary is going to play a
huge role in this story because i
personally think that the high
evolutionary made rocket raccoon because
of yondu
always referring to rocket as a rat and
the high evolutionary famously evolving
rats to become humanoid animal creatures
and so i think that what's going to
happen with adam and aisha because of
adam warlock's connection with uh the
high evolutionary is that adam is going
to try to fight the guardians like while
they're you know dealing with high
evolutionary rocket stuff and then high
evolutionary is going to be like
wow what a what a perfect child would
you like to be my son
my boy and adams could be like well my
mom's kind of crazy so yes i will be
your boy and so i don't know i feel like
there's gonna be that that high
evolutionary adam warlock teaming up
though he could use adam warlock to do
some even worse stuff so like we could
just see adam warlock becoming a uh a
temporary threat um just because he just
he was born yesterday and he's easy to
manipulate so i think that well i think
we'll see adam going from the aisha team
to
a high evolutionary team to possibly
even uh guardian of the galaxy but
that's just me that actor is really good
at playing like confused really well so
i think i think there's a reason he was
casted so i think it's that oblivious
face that he has not that he permanently
has but he's good at playing he always
plays a character that's like
i'm confused i'll go which way and i
think that plays into a lot of bro what
emcee is saying i agree like i i i would
love if like zylac or one of the
sovereign people were like hey adam so
like uh you got your paycheck and adam's
like we're getting paid yeah we're
getting paid you guys are getting paid
just like the meme you guys are getting
all that poor boy that poor boy will
never live that down yeah you're
literally a meme forever he has a meme
forever that will pull i think that
there's going to be a glimpse of him
earlier than guardians 3. i could see it
being
i could see us possibly seeing his kind
of like
training
uh
a glimpse in doctor strange multiverse
of madness like where we maybe maybe we
glimpse in to uh him kind of learning
because he is supposed to be perfect so
there's not like the learning curve is
going to be quick for him right like
he's going to emerge from that could
that
[Laughter]
[Applause]
i mean like to me the thing that makes
sense given like his kind of arcs in in
various comic books is that he'll start
off as the antagonist in guardians of
the galaxy three and then they'll
they'll all realize that they they
ultimately have similar goals or want
the same thing against a bigger villain
right like that's kind of that's kind of
seems to be what that's leading towards
but i don't know like to cast that actor
it would make sense to me to introduce
him in something earlier so that we
don't go in and have to like spend 20
minutes of guardians of the galaxy three
watching him like you know do a rocky
training montage of like now i'm
learning how to eat now i'm learning how
to walk now i'm learning how to drive a
car that's true and it's been amazing
he's like kang are you are you finishing
this drink i'm going to throw it away so
i know that's not the sexiest answer but
i think the most like where i see him
getting involved i would love i mean i
guess like to me
the opportunity that titling a movie
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness presents is like an opportunity
to open windows
into so many different marvel pro like
almost like a
like uh
like when when like tvs like when
broadcast networks would have like a
night before their shows premiered where
they would like show you like five
minutes from every new show that was
going to be on nbc like in the 90s they
would be like here's our fall preview
night like i see doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness being like our
here's our mcu preview night like we're
gonna have like shocking moments where
you're like you know almost more
genuine or like uh
the moment in deadpool when he opens the
door and there's at the uh
xavier's
the expansion and it's like they're all
just there i see more
serious versions of that happening in
that movie
i feel like there was we haven't seen
him in such a long time and also to give
credit to like the comic books he was in
the cocoon for so long and he was giving
off this like energy that people could
feel so it feels like we have to have
some better introduction than what we
saw in the
post-credits scene of the second
guardians which came out so long ago
that i i do agree with tommy where it's
like he has to be featured somewhere
else it would be kind of shitty to be
like oh remember this like out of
nowhere it's like i think the cocoon's
gonna the cocoon's gonna be connected a
lot to the character because to me when
i think adam warlock i think of that
freaking cocoon and it's such a goofy
weird thing it seems to recharge his
power like i imagine if i'm james gunn
and i'm putting adam warlock in my movie
like this guy what if he just has like
the worst battery life span like every
14 minutes he has to rebuild that cocoon
back up he's like hold on hold on i'm
like i need my 18 hours of rest is that
he's like okay here it go
and you know james gunn would play with
that so quick they'd be like wait why
can't you help anymore i gotta go back
to sleep what do you mean you gotta go
back
he's like flower and bambi he's just
always napping yeah i want him to i want
him to emerge from the cocoon though
like this like the same way people come
out of their cocoons in the matrix and
how you go down those lines oh my god
really intense watercolor
he's like this and then the bottom drops
out and he just goes
down like a flume
so he's always like he always comes
skidding in like this
has to pull his wedgie out
but no to the um to the to you i know
you brought up uh whether or not we
could see adam warlock in the holiday
special i think it's very likely that we
special because historically he's always
been like the sort of like you know
savior-ass jesus figure like when he was
like
he was specifically made as like a jesus
parallel which is very weird um so i
could definitely see them being like oh
here's the the reason for the season
adam warlock
the reason for the season
like a sovereign nativity play for how
adam warlock was born in his advent
exactly oh my god i would love that
there's a woman trying to check into a
hotel they're like there's no room here
but there is room in the manger next
door and all this [ __ ] all the asgardian
kids to just root come he's walking in
bruce playing a little drummer boy on
his trunk
oh god i hope i hope i hope i hope
[Music]
i uh i love this conversation empty
you're gonna get a point for uh bringing
in the high evolutionary i think that uh
i think you're right i think there is
gonna be a connection there in volume
three tommy you're gonna get a point for
uh that great custodian call back out of
wise
but also your uh drummer boy song just
now so tommy's in the lead guys yes
tommy big comeback and my new improv was
a big part of this and call backs were
so important
the rules change every week well we have
time for one rogue question and it's a
big one guys because timothy chalamet
revealed in an interview this week the
secret to his success quote one of my
heroes i can't say who or he'd kick my
ass um but he put his arm around me the
first night we met and it gave me some
advice
on no hard drugs
and uh no superhero movies
swish on that impression
of the emotions that was right
yeah you sound like
timothy chandelier and a half i don't
know i pronounced his last name quick
aside on timothy chalamet i love that
they put him in movies like dune when
like he's he's a like they have that
joke in tune where duncan idaho is like
you put on any muscle no you didn't like
there's no way he would exist in any
climate outside of a drama club high
school
yeah
also how is doom not basically a
superhero movie it is what are you what
are you super powers you can't see the
future what what what an arrogant
statement and also the only reason i
have a career is because of hard drugs
and superheroes
so let me just say
yeah uh i'm just josh i mean look timmy
the child i think he's a good actor i
like him in his movies i hated that i
hated that everybody exists
so yeah at this point some actor told
him no hard drugs no superhero movies
who do we think this was and what
horrible thing happened to them on the
set of a superhero movie that made them
turn to hard drugs uh i think it's
pretty obvious who it was and it's our
man
seth rogen after he hit the green horn
he's about to say son of a [ __ ]
he did he did the green hornet and he
was like
timothy weed first of all first of all
it's better for seth rogen's weed
business if people don't do hard drugs
that's right just smoke weed
he had a bad experience with a superhero
movie but i also think like the better
piece of advice would have been no hard
drugs no superhero movies and no
interviews until you're 35 and have had
life experience because yes every
interview with a 25 year old actor that
like comes out in gq or vanity fair just
makes them sound like they have never
had
any sort of life adversity at all like
they're just like well you know probably
the hardest thing for me was not getting
to see my friends during the summer when
we would go to our french villa for
eight weeks right so i would lose touch
with all my friends in america and you
have to understand when you're making
new friends who speak your second
language which i am also fluent in you
know half the time we're on a boat and
the water is noisy so you can't really
hear them and the other time we're up in
my dad's helicopter anyway i'm allergic
to caviar because i ate it so much as a
kid
like they just they all sound like out
of touch [ __ ] and i like timothy
chalamet as well and i think he's going
to be a great wonka and i hope he loses
his virginity to an oompa loompa
wouldn't that be oh wow
[Laughter]
someone yeah
i want timothy to lose his what i'm sure
is very intact virginity to uh an actor
plays
virginity intact virginity i mean
that's all i gotta say about that damn
wow
that's it though that's right
[Laughter]
but i think tommy's right we do not need
to hear any interviews from anybody
before they turn 35 just yes no not
enough life experience
uh hi um okay who do we who do we think
the other other thoughts who this was i
think it's exactly what tommy said but
as a second guess um i think it could be
will smith because like you know
is a very clean man and like he would
never be a hero
i feel like he would just
just generally just be like hey kids uh
stay away from drugs and also stay away
from superhero movies because i did
hancock and that didn't really work out
for me even though it was like skill
squad idea of he did suicide squad as
well which did also didn't work out for
him so he's uh just feeling pretty not
great about superhero movies probably
yeah that's a great guess actually i
think that one actually makes a lot of
sense i think that was the funniest one
i don't know why it is why would he go
to the fresh prince and be like any
advice you got
i mean it's real smith bro he's like
of uh of will smith i'm gonna listen to
if will smith put his arm around me he'd
be like wait a second i got a little
cocaine on my head
to tell you not to do drugs and he's
like do all the hard jobs
oh
[Laughter]
i think tommy's was great i think mt's
was great i think mine's the most
realistic i think it was ben affleck
because that man had a really hard life
not anymore not anymore jlo turned it
around but timothy timothy
timothy chamillionaire [ __ ] out of
brazil timothy chalice
timothy chalice doesn't have a j.lo so
shalom may the god right so i don't
think he is i don't think
i don't think he has a j lo so i think
ben affleck absolutely smoking a
cigarette was like look here
stay away from superhero movies also
don't do drugs don't get a giant phoenix
tattooed on your back like i did i
thought it was a good idea the artist
was really cool i thought it was a
one-night thing and it never went away
don't do it and i feel like that was a
good one because unlike will smith but i
guess kind of like will smith very
prominent person you probably would ask
him for like
tips
to be perfectly honest when that
question when eric first asked that
question i was like that's got to be ben
affleck like just logically i was like
that has to be
ben affleck because
because he also seems like the type of
person that would give you that advice
while explaining how awesome it was that
he did the opposite be like listen yeah
i've done a lot of hard drugs in my life
and had a lot of fun just pulled him
over at like the emmys and was like let
me talk to you real quick and it's like
like your older cousin at a wedding when
you're like 16 and he's like let me give
you a little advice yeah stick to the
beer don't go for the hard stuff if
anyone ever offers you any parties
powders at a party you say no i've had
the greatest nights of my life but i'll
tell you what it's not worth it because
you get laid so much and you have so
much fun and you end up on crazy
adventures but it's not worth it because
you'll say yes to things you never
thought were imaginable it'll take you
to the greatest heights but it's not
worth it it's just i mean that's why he
told him that is he he wanted it all for
himself he's like i'm coming back to
play batman i don't want this little hot
[ __ ] taking my
and he says just once i want to knock on
that door and see the you're not there
that huge update card you drove out and
you said no to all this
just once but but here's the funny thing
i actually do know who it was it was
jacob tremblay that told him that oh
yeah it was little jacob
timothy let me give you a little bit of
advice let me tell you let me tell you
timothy he's like jacob
uh well i think jess has got to get the
point for ben affleck i think that's
like that seems like most likely we came
with a lot of reasons why uh which makes
i guess her and tommy co-winners of this
week of road theory
but thank you to all of our guests uh
this week on rogue theory jessica
clements tommy bechtold and mt you can
support our channel by checking out all
of our great merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com including that
awesome venom inspired shirt follow me
at ea boss follow new rockstars on all
social platforms and be sure to
subscribe to our channel here on youtube
see you next time boners
[Music]
you